the demographic time bomb
some of the world's biggest economies
italy germany japan and china are ageing
they're running out of workers with
potentially disastrous economic and
social consequences
how can nations deal with volatile
demographic pressures
and will these pressures transform the
global balance of power for decades to
come
[Music]
[Music]
demographics rule the world
the exact combination of young and old
workers and retirees can determine a
country's economic future
[Music]
every country has a demographic sweet
spot where the majority of your
population is of working age so they're
both producing and they're consuming
great for the economy
well demographics are very important
put bluntly for advanced economies the
more people there are the larger the
economy is likely to be and the more
power and influence they're like to
wield on the global stage and that's why
the u.s is a global leader and it's why
european countries club together to
influence policy on a global level
population of the planet doubled twice
in the 20th century meaning the world
was able to create more wealth
so in 1965 there were about 3.3 billion
people on the planet now it's about 7.3
that's just just 50 years later so
that's obviously had an enormous effect
on the productive capacity of the
economy in total
but as well as growing the world's
population is aging
the average age of all the people on
earth at the start of this decade was 32
by the end of this century it will be
42.
[Music]
by 2035 1.1 billion people will be over
the age of 65.
this graying of the planet has
potentially profound economic
implications
as the population ages it means there
are more people consuming goods and
services and fewer people producing them
so simply there's just a bit less to go
around
and overall that means that economy with
an aging population is going to be
growing slower
than otherwise would
as aging
happens
people are going to save less they're
going to spend more and that's
potentially going to push up interest
rates quite significantly over the next
few decades and if you look at analysis
from former bank of england economist
charlie bean he says that's about to
happen
roughly right now we're just at that
inflection point where demographics
start to push up interest rates rather
than push down on
of the countries with the fastest
growing working age populations are in
africa or southeast asia
these countries are about to enter a
demographic window that is going to be
very
supportive of producing economic growth
india is
in the early parts of a demographic
sweet spot where the majority of their
population is now of working age this
really helps support growth
india right now in
2016 is projected to be one of if not
the fastest growing economy in the world
the demographic factors are a big
tailwind to that growth
but for more mature developed economies
the demographics are more complex and
potentially very worrying
for some economies particularly in
europe who are extremely indebted the
slowing growth of the workforce or the
shrinking of the workforce means that
those debts become less sustainable so
it actually adds to pressures that those
economies are facing
and in particular you've got sort of
italy in that camp
but actually extends to germany as well
while that's not indebted the the
demographic pressures facing germany are
actually quite significant
these demographic currents can seem
invisible and slow moving but they
affect many of the day-to-day decisions
of our governments
[Music]
i think that decisions may need to be
made do do we accept the fact that
we we do have aging demographics this
will create headwinds to us producing
growth or do we accept the fact that
we we need to accept immigrants to
rejuvenate to make the population
younger
countries that are really old if they
want to solve this problem has to ask
themselves
how many immigrants do you let in before
it actually is a cultural revolution
within your country the way of life that
you're used to is going to change
demographic trends pose similarly
dramatic problems for workers
as the population is aging it's also
living longer and healthier lives so the
expectancy probably should be that
people who are able to work will
continue to work for a bit longer
and i think to just simply to maintain
the the continued growth of living
standards for material living standards
we've seen over the past 50 years or so
people will have to work for london
stephen chan is an expert in
international politics he thinks current
trends in population point to a very
different world to come
a world where even powerful economies
like japan and china face potentially
catastrophic demographic challenges
over the next half century you are going
to see major demographic shifts there's
going to be major expansions of
population i think we may well be
entering an era not so much of despair
that may come but certainly an era to
come shortly of great frustration
because of demographic pressures
[Music]
demographic trends are changing our
world
for stephen chan these offer a unique
insight into global economics and
politics
professor chan has taught in north
america europe africa and asia and has
served as a diplomat and advisor to the
uk foreign office and u.s state
department and his fascination with how
movements of people can affect movements
in international affairs stems from his
own upbringing
my parents were refugees during world
war ii
somehow they found their way to
new zealand and they were told by the
ship captain you guys better get out
there's nothing south of here but
penguins
so
the appreciation of the need for people
to keep moving around the world that's
always been with me
what i find surprising is how people
seem to imagine that you can live in a
world without demographic shifts
in our globalized world demographics
matter
some countries will have too many people
leading to internal pressures and
migration
others will have too few leading to a
shrinking working age population
there are going to be immense
demographic changes increasingly
disturbing age profiles in many of these
countries and of course demographic
shifts as populations spill over from
one country to another the migrant or
refugee crisis for instance is a case in
point and of course there are very very
difficult concerns to do with aging
workforces for instance not enough young
people coming on stream onto the market
not enough people educated to the extent
that would be required to fulfill the
technocratic requirements of the future
world
[Music]
china the world's most populous country
has grappled with demographic crises for
much of the last 50 years
since the days of chairman mao its
governments have employed differing
strategies to handle the nation's
changing demographic trends
german mao was not the world's greatest
technocratic planner he would have
sudden whims and almost swings of mood
but i think that there was an initial
very traditional chinese impulse to
become powerful by having a very great
number of people this is something which
has a cultural ancestry now in fact it
was never viable to grow beyond a
certain point even during the early
years of the communist revolution there
were vast food shortages
the more people you have the more the
state must provide for the people within
so it's actually a burden to the state
to have too many people that's why china
decided to review the policy of growing
a population
and of course went completely to the
other extreme to try to restrict the
growth of the population
the one child policy reversed mao's
plans with dramatic results
china's fertility rate the number of
births per woman per lifetime was 5.9 in
the early 1970s
today it has fallen below 1.6
demographers estimate a country needs a
fertility rate of 2.1 to maintain a
stable population
[Music]
china is now on the edge of a
demographic cliff with potentially huge
social consequences
i think when we look at china today
we're going to be looking at a
leadership that realizes that continuing
a one-child policy is going to lead to
nothing but long-term difficulties
particularly when you have
an aging population with no one to look
after them because there's only
one child you don't have as it were a
mass of children or an extended family
with masses of children who can do the
looking after
and then
this aging population becomes a weight
on the aspirations of the younger ones
but the biggest problem is only now
becoming apparent
china's working age population started
to fall in 2012.
the world's second largest economy is
losing workers
by 2025 there will be 316 million
chinese over the age of 60.
that's almost equivalent to the entire
population of the united states today
in 2015 china abandoned the one child
policy
i think china does have major concerns
for the immediate future and the medium
term future
you're going to have this interval which
could be as long as 20 years before
these children grow up and are educated
and are able to participate in a more
competitive workforce so until that
happens there's going to be a drain not
only in terms of having to invest in the
education of these young people
but whether or not the state can support
the older people who are retiring
before the younger generation comes to
economic maturity it can help look after
them
[Music]
stephen believes china's demographics
need not be fatal though growth may be
slowing for some time
the chinese economy continues to grow
perhaps not at breakneck speed but it
has to continue to grow in such a way
that it continues to provide employment
to people in terms of the chinese impact
on the rest of the world provided the
chinese still have enough foreign
exchange to keep buying our
manufacturers
well i don't think we're going to have a
problem and certainly we're going to
continue to buy chinese manufacturers
you can't walk down a high street in
europe these days without having no
choice but to buy clothes made in china
china's government is now expecting the
nation's population to peak in 2020
before starting to fall
in japan the fall has already started
between 2010 and 2015 its population
shrank by 947
345.
by the end of this century the un
expects the country's population to fall
from
127.1 million to just 83 million
other estimates suggest the population
could more than half to just 52 million
compounding the demographic crisis
is culture
japan has got a whole
gathering a whole collaboration almost
of problems to do with demographic
shifts to do with an aging population
certainly but to do with all kinds of
social trends and social habits which no
government in japan wishes to address
the culture of seniority in japan denies
flexibility for younger workers they're
very very strict as it were social
customs that inhibit the full
participation of women in the workforce
further restricts their flexibility and
then the very very strict rules on when
you can begin taking out your pension
means that people are stuck
unproductively in work they no longer
want to do they don't want to learn new
ways of doing things and they become as
much a drain at work as they would be to
the state if they left work and into
retirement
japan has so far resisted turning to one
of the great consequences of and
possible solutions to recent demographic
trends
migration
i think one of our problems is that we
always thought that globalization would
be on our terms but now there's a
multi-faceted
globalization where there are pressures
from many many global players in
different parts of the world i don't
think that we're now going to be able to
put the genie back into the bottle in
terms of greater transit from the middle
east and north africa
to europe
that is a phenomenon which i think is
going to remain with us in one way or
another but numbers
will grow numbers will increase coming
from those parts of the world to
europe
several eu countries have their own
demographic problems
the german government expects one-third
of the population to be over the age of
65 by 2060.
europe's largest economy needs to find
more workers
[Music]
and those already in work should be
prepared to work longer and retire later
the extension of the working age is
always going to be one of these big
political hot potatoes but it's not just
a case of making people stay in
employment it has to be a certain sort
of employment how can you create the
kinds of jobs that will not only give
people employment but keep them employed
in a highly productive fashion and i
mean highly productive in terms of the
expectations of the middle part of the
21st century
three of the four biggest economies in
the world china japan and germany are
facing major demographic challenges
the choices they make increasing
fertility accepting large-scale
immigration or delaying their workers
retirement will determine whether they
remain among the most powerful nations
in the world in the decades to come
[Music]
demographic trends are rippling across
europe the continent's biggest economy
is facing a population crisis
germany has the most over 65s in the eu
the economy is already experiencing
skilled shortages in some areas
at automaker daimler over 100 retired
workers like emil canil have been
rehired to plug the gaps
[Music]
personally a benefit
outside in the middle
and then
the program acknowledges that older
workers have valuable skills
underneath
[Music]
[Applause]
for more physical tasks daimler has
modified some of its production lines to
make them more sympathetic to aging
limbs
[Music]
the uber cup stool has
started
daimler expects half its staff to be
over 50 by 2024.
foreign
[Music]
whilst german businesses prepare for an
older workforce elsewhere in europe
immigration offers another way to defuse
the demographic time bomb
this is satriano in italy
a town at the heart of europe's
demographic crisis
o.g
[Music]
[Music]
italy's birth rate has been falling for
50 years and is at the lowest level
since unification in 1861.
the italian government is now paying
villages like satriano to take in
migrants from around the world
the hope is that new blood will stem
satriano's and italy's demographic
decline
[Music]
is
[Music]
the journey is made by many of the new
arrivals like adnan a testament to the
demographic flows sweeping the globe
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you
it's too early to say if this kind of
managed migration will reverse italy's
demographic fortunes but it has made
satriano a livelier place
and serves as a reminder that
demographic trends have touched every
community in the world at some time in
the past
[Music]
foreign demographic shifts are occurring
all the time in every country
being able to anticipate them early
enough is the key to a nation's future
prosperity
you can boil it down this way
when you have citizens there's two ways
they could add to the economy
they could produce
and they can consume
when you have too many people above a
certain age and they leave the labor
force
suddenly you have people in your economy
who are consuming but are no longer
producing
this makes it much harder for a country
to grow
governments that don't have a long-term
wise policy
will face demographic consequences or
rather their successes will face
demographic consequences i think that
those countries that have got policies
that are able to cater for their
demographic changes are the ones are
going to be successful in the future
[Music]
our world is a divided and unequal place
a competitive economy you'll always have
some inequality and obviously you'll
have those who are very successful and
some who are less so but the issue is
the extreme one percent of the
wealthiest population
holds more than half of the world's
wealth
62 wealthiest people hold
the same kind of wealth as the lowest 50
of the world population
it's a very striking statistic indeed if
you look at
ceo pay you know it's gone from about 50
times the average worker 30 years ago to
300 times now potentially not only does
it issue for investors it's also an
issue for for workers
[Music]
inequality has become the hot button
economic issue of the 21st century but
worrying about inequality is not new
if we look way back into u.s history we
saw dramatic income inequality in for
instance the gilded age the 1880s and
the 1890s
and it went so far
and then it collapsed and policies were
put in place by a number of presidents
and administrations to sort of uh
equalize the playing field uh labor laws
were put in place tax laws were changed
and that prevailed through the course of
world war ii and into the 1960s
but then by the 1980s tax laws were
changed and the economy had changed
and so from the early 1980s to present
we've seen income inequality
on the rise
it matters because income inequality
eventually contributes uh to wealth
inequality with wealth comes power in
terms of
politics and
corporate leadership and lots of
different
facets of the economy and so when
much wealth is held by a very few
individuals within an economy or within
a country
then those individuals tend to have an
outsized degree of control over economic
and political policy making and
therefore they are able to
incorporate policies that will even
further increase their levels of wealth
inequality is about more than fairness
economists worry extreme levels of
inequality can have dramatic effects on
the finances of corporations and
governments
it really affects
the pace at which
will the world economy is growing so
uh to give you an example the wealthiest
as they get more money they tend to
spend less of a marginal dollar so this
way you get less consumption and
consequently less growth in the economy
so that's one uh kind of a consequence
another thing is that lower and medium
income families tend to borrow more to
support their consumption and it creates
risks
some of the most dramatic levels of
inequality can be seen in the developing
world
here inequality appears to have a
corrosive effect on the whole economy
something else that we've seen in
emerging markets is a correlation
between
inequality
and corruption levels
where government is not effective you
aren't necessarily getting education in
place and the rules to to allow everyone
to succeed if you look at the arab
spring in north africa and the middle
east you know at root cause was you know
economic opportunity and so if you have
this extreme inequality if you have a
lack of economic opportunity you know
you could potentially have a political
unrest
if you're at the top of the pile it's
tempting to think inequality does not
affect you
but this may be dangerously complacent
clearly inequality is very bad for the
people at the bottom especially if the
bottom is very low i think at the top um
there's a potential risk to you know
what what could extreme inequality breed
could it lead to political unrest um
could it lead to new rules
new taxation so i think you know in the
short term even if you're at the the top
of the economic permit you may be very
happy with your position but long term i
think there's potential for for change
which may be destabilizing if you think
about it in a broader sense and think
about economic growth and future
generations it's a bad thing because
that actually could impact economic
growth uh in
in the world
so i would say that it's a it's a
problem for everybody
one global economist is convinced
inequality is dramatically affecting
human life in even the richest parts of
the world
and that if we want to maximize growth
and social cohesion it's an issue we can
no longer ignore
absolute income inequality is where i
think we have to have a real debate
there are clear knock-on effects and
whether there are an education access
health care
options but also political and life
expectancy challenges it's very much the
case that income inequality is now a
driver in some of these other factors
[Music]
inequality is one of the most hotly
debated issues in economics from new
york to nairobi
dambisa moyo is a global economist
her work for the world bank and on wall
street has seen her named one of the
most influential people in the world
she's fascinated by the biggest trends
in economics from the politics of
development in africa
to the price of commodities in china
now she's turning her attention to
inequality
[Music]
income inequality is particularly
problematic inasmuch as it is a
defining factor in many societies for
where
a society's living standards are going
the date on income inequality has shown
that it has gotten worse over the last
several decades
in fact over the past 30 years we have
seen income inequality worsen across the
united states the united kingdom and
across much of
europe in the same vein we've seen that
the average income of the top one
percent in the united states today is 30
times the average income of the rest of
the populations and the rest of the 99
percent
compare this with 30 years ago in 1978
when it was simply 10 times
higher for the top 1
[Music]
economists worry that inequality ushers
in a range of social problems
recent studies in mexico suggest that
neighborhoods with high levels of
inequality may suffer more violent crime
than those where inequality is less
pronounced researchers in other nations
have come to similar conclusions
a problem with income inequality is the
implications and impact that it has on a
society and the question being is it
possible for people of different income
levels and without prospects of
improving their lives to live cheek by
zhao
for example in the united states the
bronx is the poorest congressional
district in the united states but it's
also 20 minutes by train about five
stops to one of the richest enclaves in
the world in the upper east side of
manhattan
there are real questions around whether
that sort of a living cheek by gel is
actually long-term sustainable given
risks of crime and also destitution
there are knock-on effects for other
forms of inequality such as health or
education and of course political
inequality
in the united states approximately 158
families are responsible for
approximately 50 percent of campaign
funding around the u.s election system
and that really does pose the question
about where democracy stands and how
that might play in
to the political representation
of the democratic process
americans have always prided themselves
on levels of social mobility within
their country the ability of people to
get ahead whatever circumstances they
were born into
but some recent evidence suggests this
is changing
there is a more fundamental aspect to
dealing with the incoming inequality
challenge which i would argue revolves
around social mobility and social
mobility really is about people's belief
and people's access and opportunity to
improving their living standards and
their livelihoods over um a period of
time i think that the cause of income
inequality is the breakdown of social
mobility particularly in western
societies so just to give you a flavor
for that
today in the united states
if you are born into the bottom twenty
percent of the income level then you
have only five percent chance of ending
up your life in the top 20
without the college degree
clearly that suggests that income
inequality is widening and i think also
it shows that there's a real issue
around social mobility and people's
ability to actually transform their
lives and to move into higher levels of
income
[Music]
as well as hindering social mobility
extreme levels of income inequality may
depress growth across whole economies
the reason that this is so important is
that the oecd estimates that this is
costing those developed countries
approximately eight and a half percent
gdp points um over this period so put
another way because of income inequality
and the widening effects of the gap
between the richest and the poorest in
the u.s and across europe we have seen
gdp growth slow by about 8.5
over the past 25 years
today there are real concerns about how
this bodes for the longer term and for
the future a lot of projections now show
that economic growth will be slowing and
obviously the knock-on effects of income
inequality are likely to be worse
[Music]
this means inequality is not just a
problem for those at the bottom of the
economic pile
chronic income inequality may well
affect the social and economic health of
everyone
if you are wealthy and living in a uh in
an urban setting for example
the fact that you every day are dealing
with people who have a lower income
levels but more importantly have fewer
prospects to improve their livelihoods
has an absolute direct impact on your
safety but also on your own living
standards to the extent that society as
a whole will not likely be growing and
so it's not just about
lower living standards for those that
proportion of societies about lower
living standards for its entirety in the
society because the growth of a society
is
highly linked to how the average person
in society is performing
[Music]
dambisa believes the key to tackling
inequality lies in reactivating social
mobility but to do that citizens basic
needs in terms of health and education
must be catered for first
i think that the thing that is a
paramount an urgency is to ensure that
all citizens and particularly people who
are at the lower levels of income are
seeing improvements in their living
standards over the long period of time
the real underlying challenges of income
inequality in a broader sense which i
would argue really are hitched to the
idea of social mobility and the
challenges there
but social mobility is propelled by
economic growth
and without economic growth inequality
will rise
just to be absolutely clear on that we
need to aim for at least seven percent
um gdp growth every year in order to
double per capita incomes in one
generation we are far below that target
so it's really the case that we do have
real issues around um what the long-term
prospects for economic growth are but
therefore what the long-term prospects
for social mobility and our ability to
reduce income inequality are
[Music]
if the problem of inequality is worrying
for the west then it's compounded in
countries with fast growing young
populations
if these economies are to have any
chance of tackling inequality they must
create millions of jobs first
beyond just the developed countries of
course there's a real concern around
income inequality widening particularly
in the faster growing largest emerging
market economies such as brazil india
and south africa today there are
approximately 85 million young people
mainly in the emerging markets between
the ages of 18 and 25 that are out of
work if we are going to try and solve
the income inequality challenge we first
have to make sure we've got growth but
we also have to make sure that we are
providing incomes
that are growing
to this young population
we also have to make sure that people
have improved access to education and to
health care so that they have the social
infrastructure to improve their lives
and therefore support social mobility
without those factors there is a real
risk that living standards of not just
the impoverished
percentage of the population but society
as a whole starts to deteriorate
[Music]
south africa is one of the most unequal
countries in the world
here the consequences of inequality on
the safety of society are visible and
real
but businesses are trying to restart
social mobility and save the economy
[Music]
inequality is one of the defining
challenges of our age
in south africa the most unequal country
on the continent its consequences can be
seen in the continuing poverty of large
parts of the country
and in the visceral fear of crime that
defines the wealthiest suburbs
taking a look at the big picture
and the
the well-being of a country in the long
run
it is very unhealthy
to have this dramatic distribution of
of wealth and inequality it will not be
a successful model to live in a world
where the haves are isolated into
communities uh with very high walls
around those communities while the
have-nots are
sitting at the gates begging for table
scraps
[Music]
in south africa there are more private
security guards than police officers
they patrol the country's gated suburbs
under the most visible example of an
unequal society
crime is bad in your home out of your
home
basically all over i don't want it to
sound like it's terrifying we live with
it and we have good lives here
however trying to keep
your family safe trying to keep your
home safe has become more and more
difficult and that is what we focus on
css tactical is a johannesburg based
private security firm employing 750
people
so our approach is very much multiple
layers of security so you would have
your armed response you would have your
proactive patrolling so the vehicle is
not just sitting under a tree waiting to
be dispatched they're actually present
in the area they're patrolling they're
driving up and down streets and we've
got very intelligent software that
actually alerts on unusual behavior so
if you're walking down the streets five
o'clock in the afternoon going home from
work that's normal but three o'clock in
the morning on that side of the street
is abnormal so there's again a tension
on what is going on in the suburb as
opposed to just sitting under a tree
waiting for
an alarm to go
fear of crime is splitting johannesburg
in two
the city experienced over 21 000
burglaries last year
johannesburg is the financial capital so
hence a
greater concentration of i guess wealth
and wealthy people and lots of stuff to
steal lots of stuff that can that you
can see to steal there's a massive
difference between the haves and the
have-nots i mean unemployment is rife um
and i think
unfortunately people have not seen that
you know crime is is a way to make a
living
south africa is now more unequal than it
was under apartheid
but some businesses across the country
are actively trying to address this and
get social mobility moving again
so i was pregnant with my first daughter
and i was at home we lived in a farm so
i was at home during the day and i would
chat to the ladies that worked in the
fields next door and that sort of thing
and they were picking lettuces and
whatever but they really had
you know they would they had so much
inside of them but they had no
opportunity to go anywhere there was no
opportunity for training or to to get a
bit further or anything and also what i
realized there was no power of
possibility
erin along with her sister maeve decided
to set up mangua nani a health spa
their plan was to recruit their staff
from among the rural poor
it was literally there's a couple of
ladies from the field next door so
everybody went home and found sisters
and aunts and whatever they were
unemployed and of course we trained them
up i realized the importance and what
manguni could actually do in south
africa i realized that very very quickly
and
realizing then the amount of lives you
could change
[Music]
christine boudelesi was one of the first
women that erin and maeve employed
i was on my way i remember one weekend
going to church
then i met maeve who gave me a lift and
she started chatting to me are you
working what are you doing at the moment
i was still at school and everything
then i said to her no currently i'm
working at a farm it was a chicken farm
where
we were paid like 20 rent a day
then she said but why don't you come and
join mango
then after a week i said you know what
i've got nothing to use so i went for my
training then from there started working
at the spa as a therapist i started from
the bottom
like doing massages which i really
enjoyed it then within three months and
i moved into becoming one of the treaty
managers and then i think within a year
i was promoted to be a general manager
which for me it was such
a growth in such a small time
has become a prolific job creation
scheme expanding across south africa and
propelling women like christine from
rural poverty to senior managerial
positions
we estimate that we've trained about 20
000 people we had ladies that had been
with us for say eight nine years and it
really reached the top they were now
managers and i'm also proud to say that
every single one of our spots is run by
a lady who came up through the ranks
[Music]
erin is going further rolling out plans
across her 20 spas to give shares in the
business to its employees
at the moment in quesadilla tell our
staff own 30
of their business i wanted them to be
part of the business because when you're
doing that many treatments in a day
you're giving so much of yourself
by training staff giving them a route to
move up the pay grades and offering the
mistake in their own business erin hopes
her firm can help tackle inequality in
south africa
i can look after my kids i can look
after my family you know with us black
communities we've got so many families
that we take care of like i'm a
breadwinner at home everybody depends on
me as much as you've got the other
people that are working but most of the
time i'm the one who's taking that whole
responsibility so mango nani has given
us
like
growth like giving us hope
it has made us like dreamers
inequality has come to define south
africa's economy but if more can be done
to reactivate social mobility there's a
chance that this will not be the case
for long
when households are really in a grinding
state of poverty they can't contribute a
whole lot
to economic well-being so as
lower income demographics are lifted up
into
working class or middle class thresholds
they tend to be better educated there's
less crime there's a stronger family
structure and they tend to be a lot more
productive
in terms of the economy and they also
consume and invest a lot more as well a
strong middle class a strong working
class
is really the backbone of a healthy
democracy i feel i'm cautiously
optimistic about the future i believe
that the path towards a world of
economic growth of social mobility and
improved
income inequality statistics is one that
is possible but not without there being
hard choices whether it's increasing
economic growth increasing social
mobility we have to make sure that we're
addressing those factors to avoid a
situation where society and the members
of the society become so disaffected
[Music]
fossil fuels have built our world
coal and oil found deep within the earth
are carbon rich resources which pack a
mighty punch
they're abundant they're easy to
transport and store
if we weren't digging up fossil fuels we
couldn't have had an industrial
revolution a lot of our agriculture
would be impossible we probably have
great difficulty feeding our current
population never mind having smartphones
and electricity and all these things
certainly it would have been difficult
to build our civilization without fossil
fuels
nearly 100 million barrels of oil are
used around the world every day
in 2014 fossil fuels accounted for 85 of
world energy consumption
but governments are worried about
climate change and pollution
we see this in the world cities from
shanghai to mumbai and even to new york
paris london
air pollution is becoming an
increasingly important issue politically
and of course you've also got climate
change increasingly policy makers world
over recognize the need to act
fossil fuels present a political
challenge for the west
the biggest oil reserves are found in
regions which are often hostile or
unstable
as well as political worries
consumer habits are changing
[Music]
historically the energy system has been
driven by big investment decisions made
by big energy companies supported by
government and increasingly consumers
have more choice that enables them to
make energy to decisions of their own
for example they might choose to put
solar on their roofs they might choose
to invest in the increasing number of
energy storage options they might buy an
electric vehicle
until recently we were we were sort of
dumb consumers we had no information
about what we were buying uh how much we
were using and that's that's changing
very rapidly
but removing fossil fuels from our
energy mix is a daunting task one which
could potentially shake our economies to
their core
if we flipped to switch overnight and
switched from fossil fuels to renewables
i think there would be widespread chaos
because honestly we haven't really
figured out even how we would do it
but the cost of energy is changing
the financial shocks of the early 21st
century may have disrupted the economics
of the energy market
[Music]
i think the financial crisis had two
effects
the first was it generated over 190
billion us dollars of stimulus funding
for the green economy industrial output
fell electricity and energy demand fell
households became more thrifty they're
more mindful of their energy consumption
they started thinking about ways to
reduce their bills
but you combine weaker demand with more
renewable energy and what you created
was the beginnings of the disruption
that we currently witness
the results of this disruption can be
seen around the world
so as of 2014 greece was generating 9.5
percent of its electricity from solar
italy was generating 8.7 percent and
germany 6.3 percent of its electricity
from solar now those are not massive
numbers but they do illustrate that you
can have a real economy that runs
substantially off intermittent
renewables without the sky falling
solar itself has come down about 75
percent
um in the last five years
wind energy has got about 25 cheaper
over the last five years so those two
technologies are now competing directly
with the more traditional conventional
sources of electricity now the question
is how do you integrate a system which
has variable and intermittent supply and
increasingly choppy demand
and the technical side of how do you
make that work in a much lower carbon
environment
tony sieber is a writer academic and
renewable energy investor who believes
not only will we make renewables work
but that we are already in the midst of
an energy disruption which by 2030 will
signal the end of the fossil fuel
economy this disruption will transform
the lives of every person on the planet
and what's driving it is not pollution
or politics
it's price
it's soon going to be
in everybody's best
selfish economic interest to have solar
panels and batteries and electric
vehicles it's purely economics and
that's how technology disruptions happen
purely economics
[Music]
tony sieber is a stanford university
academic and renewable energy investor
who has spent a lifetime studying how
the rise and fall of technology can
change the world
he believes we are now experiencing one
of the most significant technological
disruptions in modern history
[Music]
a clean disruption which by 2030 will
herald the end of our current energy mix
and the birth of cleaner power in every
corner of the world
there are four essential technologies
that are going to disrupt all of energy
and transportation
batteries
solar energy electric vehicles and
autonomous cars
and these are all disruptive in their
own way
but when you combine them it's
super disruptive it's exponentially
disruptive
and that combination is going to
make all of energy and transportation
obsolete
[Music]
people fear disruptions
but tony sieber believes they shouldn't
what happens in disruptions is that
there is a destruction
of wealth
but also there's a creation of new
wealth so the web destroyed a lot of the
old publishing
wealth but also if you look at
the top
web companies the top internet companies
that's 2.4 trillion dollars
in market valuation 2.4 trillion dollars
this is the new wealth
tony is a long-term investor in solar
energy which he believes is leading this
clean disruption
accounts for barely one percent of world
energy today its growth has been rapid
and its costs are falling
the adoption
of solar has been doubling
every two years since 1990.
in australia
there are one and a half million homes
with solar energy that's 25 percent of
the population
solar in australia
on the rooftop unsubsidized is cheaper
than the cost of transmission
so think about what that does to the
existing business model of central
generation
even if you can generate at zero in your
nuclear or coal plant or whatever
when you add the cost of transmission
you still cannot compete with solar
renewables have historically been
plagued by the problem of storage the
ability to keep enough energy in reserve
when the sun doesn't shine and the wind
doesn't blow
but here too the economics are changing
so lithium-ion batteries are the
form of energy storage that are winning
right now
and lithium-ion batteries have been
improving
at about 16
per year
on a dollar per kilowatt-hour basis
so if you keep that sixteen percent uh
cost curve going
essentially
by 2020
the average american household which
consumes
more electricity than anyone on earth
per capita
will be able to store a full day of
electricity for a dollar a day
in australia it's already becoming
financially viable
to store a few hours of electricity
and within four years five years it's
going to be
basically for the cost of a latte you'll
be able to store several hours of
sunshine every day for the cost of a
latte
solar is already
cheaper
unsubsidized than any other form of
energy so we're getting to the tipping
point
and in technology
what happens with the tipping point
is that it accelerates
demand accelerates dramatically and
disruptions happen very quickly
the point at which
rooftop solar plus the battery in your
home in your factory in your business in
your hotel
becomes cheaper than the cost of
transmission
that is going to happen sometime between
2019 and 2022 everywhere on earth
this disruption will transform not just
our homes but the way we get from a to b
transportation is undergoing the most
massive disruption
in a century essentially the last time
we went through this disruption was when
we went from horses
to uh electric street cars and and
internal combustion engine cars which
happened a little more than 100 years
ago
so essentially three things are going to
happen in transportation are already
happening in transportation
all vehicles
will go from internal combustion engine
basically fossil fuel powered to
electric vehicles they're going to go
from 100
human driven
to 100
computer driven and it's going to go
from car ownership to essentially not
owning a car
the implications for companies that
build cars are enormous it could mean
the end of the automotive industry as we
know it
when
vehicles go to all electric self-driving
and car share
we're going to get the same level of
service basically you're going to have a
car picking you up at home taking you to
work and then taking you to the bar and
then taking it to the supermarket and
then back home
for 90 percent less cost
and the implications reach far beyond
who build sells and drives cars
tony believes the design of our cities
the urban fabric of our lives could
change forever
now
what's going to happen then
is that the number of cars
that we need
is going to go down so
think about
cities like los angeles where 60
of the landmass
is parking and roads
um basically 80 percent of that is going
to be obsolete so this is going to give
us
this is going to give the world
for the first time in a century
the possibility
to
redesign our cities to totally redesign
the landscape
how we want our cities to be
[Music]
taken together these changes amount to
almost a complete revolution in energy
use
whilst oil may still be needed for
aviation and the manufacture of plastics
tony thinks demand for fossil fuels
fuels which have built the world as we
know it is about to collapse
oil is going to go through what salt
went through in the middle ages so 60
of petroleum
goes into transportation 60
that's gone things like coal
gone we're going to have zero need for
coal things like natural gas
except for fertilizers gone that market
is going to implode totally
it took decades for oil to dominate the
world economy
tony believes the dominance of renewable
energy will happen much more quickly
when we transitioned from biomass to
coal to oil and what so so on and so
forth we went from one type of
extraction
of mining
energy resources to another and those
transitions took a long time 50 or 100
years but technology disruptions
don't take place in 100 years they take
place in months solar is a technology
the energy source is the sun
it's free so we don't need to go
necessarily from one extraction to
another
it's basically solar panels period
in the same thing with electric vehicles
it's a technology
the shape of renewable technology is
changing all the time technology now
exists to manufacture transparent solar
panels
now when we think solar
we think rooftops
but in the not too distant future in
only a few years
we'll be able to
convert our windows i mean imagine every
time you look up and you see one of
these high rises
full of windows
that could be a three megawatt solar
power plant if all we do
is go through the existing technology
cost curve
for batteries and solar and electric
vehicles and autonomous vehicles
essentially all of energy and
transportation is going to be obsolete
by 2030.
the clean disruption tony foresees has
huge political implications it has the
potential to transform the economies of
entire nations and change the balance of
power across the world
for the middle east the implications are
massive because when the west does not
value
when oil has no strategic value
then
are we the west
going to be involved in the middle east
the way we're involved now no we're not
right so the countries california or
korea or germany or china the countries
that lead the clean disruption
are going to be the countries that lead
the 21st century
[Music]
in the north african desert one country
is embracing this bright future
[Music]
morocco has just switched on the world's
largest solar power plant
soon energy from these skies will be
exported to the richest economies in the
world
with the potential to transform the
lives of millions
tony sieber is an academic and investor
in renewable energy he believes we're in
the midst of a dramatic energy
transition
at the center of this is solar power
enough sun falls on the surface of the
earth in one hour to power the entire
planet for one year but the technology
needed to capture it store it and export
it has been problematic
until now
here on the left you can see the
norwan power plant solar power plant so
as you can see you have a very big solar
field with the parabolic mirrors
and you have
about 480 hectares
of what is the the total uh area
this is the newer one solar power plant
in wazasat on the edge of the sahara
desert in morocco
the first of four gigantic plants which
when finished will combine to make the
largest concentrated power plant in the
world
we have a surface of
1.4 million square meters of mirrors
so it's about 500 000 mirrors
they're separated in seven areas because
of the altitude and because of the water
drainage system
it's going to be
enough
to provide energy for two
million people
the noor project uses new technology to
overcome one of the biggest drawbacks of
solar power the inability to deliver
energy when the sun is not shining
the focal axis in the very center you
have a liquid that is called htf heat
transfer fluid
so all the the radiation the rays of the
of the sun uh are converging in in this
fluid
so you can see there we have two tanks
very big tanks with 45 000 tons
of
molten salts that uh keep the energy
after uh an exchange heat exchange with
the with the with the htf
for about three hours so in case we need
to produce electricity after the sunset
we can take this
salt
and make an exchange with the htf
underwater to produce again in the night
for the future plants that are being
built right now we are we will be able
to produce between seven to eight hours
of extra production during the night
nor promises the possibility of 24-hour
solar power
it also promises to transform the
economy of morocco which imports 94
percent of its energy from abroad
as well as transforming morocco's
economy solar could turn the nation into
an energy exporter
[Music]
plus
[Music]
[Music]
elsewhere in africa a more modest but no
less significant technology is being
developed
millions of disused plastic bags float
across the south african countryside
rithaka is a startup which has pioneered
a way of turning this dirty plastic into
clean energy
[Music]
firstly
they bring the plastics from the damping
site and then we have the station we
call it washing station there at washing
station they wash the plastics
after we've got the iron
that we ironed that plastic so it's
become a sheet a heart sheet that can
make that we make a school bag then we
go to a cutting station where they cut
the pattern
then after the pattern it goes to the
machinist then sew the screw back
these school bags are fitted with a
solar powered charger they charge during
the day
and provide light at night
here is the solar panel that goes with
the school back
so when the child goes to school it
charges on the sun so it stays like this
then after
we're going to put it back on the jar
in the afternoon maybe when she's doing
a homework
then we're going to put it back
and
it's going to light it
that's how it works
the aim is to solve three problems
eliminate a plague of plastic litter
provide light for the poorest students
and provide safe electricity to families
who often use kerosene or other
dangerous fuels to light their homes
you don't use electricity you don't have
to spend money to use it so it helps a
lot because like the poor people they
use it a lot
this factory is making 500 school bags a
month
[Music]
it's an example of how energy is moving
away from large-scale utilities into the
hands of small businesses and
individuals
and from fossil fuels to renewable power
[Music]
150 years after the birth of the modern
oil industry
are we about to enter a new era of
energy
[Music]
i think to bet against the renewable
energy sector is to bet against
modernization it's to bet against
technology it's to bet against climate
science
and you start to have to make a whole
lot of bets a whole lot of bets that
don't look great by themselves
[Applause]
we don't need breakthroughs
in solar or wind we don't need
breakthroughs in autonomous vehicles we
don't need breakthroughs and batteries
if all we do is
take the existing technology cost curve
and the existing improvements of these
technologies essentially this clean
disruption is going to happen and it's
inevitable and it's going to happen
before 2030.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you